[موسيقى]
مساء الخير بعد شهور من التردد يبدو ان
المانيا قدرات دخل الضغوط الغربيه وقررت
تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابه لبرد 2 وهناك
مجموعه من الاسئله التي تطرح نفسها السؤال
الاول لماذا كل هذا الجدل والضجه حول
الدبابه لبرد 2 لماذا يصير الجيش
الاوكراني على هذه الدبابه دون غيرها
لماذا تردد الالمان 11 شهرا قبل ان
يوافقوا والاهم ماذا يعني ان يحصل
الاوكران على الدبابه الالمانيه المتطوره
قبل محاوله الاجابه على هذه الاسئله
اذكركم من ان انا استخدمت كلمه يبدو في
بدايه كلامه كنوع من التحفظ لان الاعلان
الرسمي عن الموافقه الالمانيه اعطاء
الاوكران هذه الدبابه لم يتم حتى وقت
تسجيل الحلقه
ظهر يوم 25 يناير 2023
والموافقه حتى هذه اللحظه عباره عن
تصريحات خارج التسجيل وتسريبات من مسؤولين
الان وامريكان لوسائل اعلام كبيره مثل سي
ان ان والاستريت جيرمن همم سبيجل
الالمانيه الاعلان الرسمي من المفترض ان
يتم من جانب الحكومه الالمانيه خلال ساعات
لكن المفاجات دائما وارده
نعود الى اجابه الاسئله التي طرحتها في
بدايه الحلقه والاجابه عليها تقتدي ان
نفهم السياق العام والسياق العام بسيط جدا
الجيش الاوكراني منذ اندلاع الحرب في
فبراير من العام الماضي وله طلب واحد رئيس
صبيحه كل يوم من كل حلفائه من حلف شمال
الاطلسي والدول خارج حلف شمال الاطلسي
السلاح ثم السلاح ثم السلاح اي نوع من
السلاح السلاح الروسي في المقام الاول
والسلاح الغربي في المقام الثاني لماذا
السلاح الروسي في المقام الاول
لان التسليح والعقيده عقيده الجيش
الاوكراني هي تسليح وعقيده روسيه بامتياز
وبالتالي الاسهل للجيش الاوكراني ان يحصل
على مزيد من الاسلحه الروسيه لتعويض ما
يفقده من هذه الاسلحه في المواجهات مع
الروس وتعود عليها يجيد استخدامها يدخل
صيانتها لن يحتاج وقت لتدريب ضباته وجنوده
على هذه المنظومات كما هو الحال في
منظومات التسليح الغربيه التي لم يلفها هو
بصفه عامه حلف شمال الاطلسي بدا يبحث عن
الاسلحه الروسيه في مخازن كل الدول
الصديقه والحليفه بكل انواعها ويلقيها
للجيش الاخراني وبما اننا نتحدث عن
الدبابات سوف اعطيكم مثال مهم
وسائل الاعلام كشفت منذ اسابيع على ان
الولايات المتحده اقنعت المملكه المغربيه
بان تعطي
ما لديها من دبابات تي 72 الروسيه الى
الجانب الاوكراني بعد ان يتم تطويرها في
شركه اكس كاليبر التشيكيه المملكه
المغربيه لم تؤكد صحه هذه التقارير
وبالتالي قد يكون التقرير صحيح وقد يكون
غير صحيح لكن المؤكد ان شركه اكس كلبر
التشيكيه اعلنت ان عشرات الدبابات
قدرتها بحوالي 120 دبابه قد اتاتها من
دوله افريقيه لم تسميها وان هذه الدبابات
سوف تتم
بتمويلا سوف يتم تجديدها بتمويل الامريكي
ثم سوف تذهب الى اوكرانيا في نهايه المطاف
بالاضافه للاسلحه الروسيه
بدا الجيش الاوكراني يطالب الغرب بمنظومات
تسليح الغربيه متطوره في البدايه امتنع
الغربه عن تزويد اوكرانيا الا باسلحه
يعتبرها دفاعيه بامتياز وبالتالي فيما
يتعلق بالدبابات لم يقدم حلف شمال الاطلسي
الا ناقلات الجند المدرعه الدبابات
الخفيفه ورفضوا تماما ان يعطوه ما يسمى
بدبابه القتال الرئيسيه ما هي دبابه
القتال الرئيسيه وما الفرق بينها وبين
الدبابات الخفيفه او ناقلات الجند المدرعه
ناقله الجند المدرعه عباره عن عربات بتنقل
المشاه من مكان الى مكان مثل اللورس لكنها
ليست مكشوفه مثل العربيات اللوري يعني
عباره عن عربيات مدرعه مدرعه اي محميه من
القذائف المختلفه واا يعني قدرتها على
القتال محدوده جدا لان هدفها نقل الجنود
من مكان الى اخر
الدبابات الخفيفه اكثر تدريعا اكثر قدره
على اطلاق النيران اما دبابه القتال
الرئيسيه فلديها امكانيات كبيره جدا قدره
هائله على القتال والاشتباك واختراق صفوف
العدو مدرعه من اسفل ضد اربع مختلفه من
الالغام مدرعه من اعلى بشكل قوي جدا
لحمايه من يستخدمها من الجنود عندها مدافع
لديها قدره كبيره جدا على انتاج النيران
مسوده باسلحه همم متطوره للتشويش على
اجهزه رادار العدو عندها قدره كبيره على
العمل ليلا والرؤيه ليليه دقه التصويب
المناوره السرعه الى اخره
الاوكران منذ بدايه الحرب وقع اختيارهم
على الدبابه ليبر 2 وتقدمه هم كانوا يعني
الحقيقه يعني يتمنوا احدى الدباب دبابتين
اما ام 1 ابرامز الامريكيه او ليبرت تو
الالمانيه ابرامز الامريكيه كانت خارج
المناقشه رفض الامريكانو قولا واحدا منذ
البدايه ولذلك اهتم الاوكراني منذ البدايه
بالليبر تو الالمانيه وتقدموا بطلب رسمي
للسلطات الالمانيه متى تقدموا يعني في
الايام الاولى اللي اندلاع الحرب تحديدا
في ثلاثه مارس 2022 اي بعد سبعه ايام فقط
من اندلاع المواجهات العسكريه او الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا
اذا المساله ليست جديده ما الذي جددها
الذي جددها انه مجريات الحرب في ميدان
المعركه انه في قناه اولا في كثير من
الخطوط الحمراء اللي كانت بتحكم هذا
الصراع مع طول اماده بدات تتلاشى وبدا
الغرب يقدم اسلحه صعب ان يتم وصفها بانها
اسلحه دفاعيه ثم انه القناعه لدى الاقران
ولده حلفاء اوكرانيا ان الجيش الروسي
يستعد لهجوم شامل مره اخرى على كثير من
المدن الاخرانيه وهناك تخطيط اوكراني
بضروره الاستعداد لهجوم المضاد على القوات
الروسيه
لاسترداد الاراضي التي احتلوها على الاقل
منذ فبراير 2022 وبالتالي يستعد الجيش
الاوكراني لهذا الهجوم الروسي من ناحيته
والهجوم المضاد الذي يعتزمون القيام به
على القوات الروسيه في المدن التي احتلوها
من ناحيه اخرى في الحالتين هم في حاجه
للتزوج باكبر عدد ممكن من الدبابات حددوا
احتياجاتهم ب 300 دبابه بالاضافه طبعا
الاحتياجاتهم من المدافع والصواريخ الى
اخره
وركزوا على الدبابه لبرد 2 لماذا ليبردو 2
اولا لانها واحده من افضل الدبابات في
العالم ثانيا لانها متوفره جدا في يعني
مخازن الدول الصديقه التقديرات بتقول ان
هذه الدبابه لبرد 2 التي دخلت الخدمه
بدايه من عام 1979
اييه موجود منها اكثر من 2000 دبابه في 13
دوله اوروبيه وبالتالي الفكره اللي راقت
للجيش الاوكراني واللي هي موجوده في عقل
صانع القرار في حلف شمال الاطلسي وفي
الولايات المتحده انه من الافضل ان
تعطي كل دوله من الدول التي تملك لبرد 2
من الدول الاوروبيه جزءا من ما لديها من
ليبر تو اذا تنازلت كل دوله عن جزء سوف
تستطيع ان تؤمن اوكراني احتياجاتها اللي
هي بتقدرها بحوالي 300 دبابه وبالتالي لا
تتاثر سلبا مغصونات هذه الدول ولا تتاثر
قدرته على الدفاع عن نفسها
لكن المخطط ده بيعتمد على موافقه المانيا
ليه موافقه المانيا اولا لان المانيا هي
الدوله المصنعه وبالتالي سوف تكون هي
صاحبه النصيب الاكبر من اعطاء هذه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا اثنين انه في عالم
السلاح اي دوله بتستورد سلاح من دوله اذا
ارادت الدوله المستورده ان تعطي هذا
السلاح لطرف ثالث
فموافقه دوله المنشا او الدوله المصنعه
ضروريه جدا وبالتالي اذا اعطت المانيا هذا
السلاح ليه بولندا فرنسا المانيا همم
انجلترا هولندا فنلندا واذا ارادت واحده
من هذه الدول ان تعطي ما لديها من ليبرتو
الى اوكرانيا فلا بد من موافقه المانيا
والمانيا رفضت على مدار 11 شهرا لماذا
رفضت المانيا على مدى 11 شهرا له اربعه
اسباب رئيسيه السبب الاولاني تاريخي
وتتحدثنا عنه قبل ذلك المانيا
بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه قررت
ان تضع السلاح جانبا وان تتوقف عن الحروب
ويعني لسان حالها انا مليت من الحروب حرب
العالميه الثانيه الحرب العالميه الاولى
عشرات الحروب على مدار سنوات طويله سبقت
الحرب العالميه الاولى مع جيرانها دفعت
فاتوره غاليه جدا تورطت في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في جرائم يعني هي بتخجل منها تحت
حكم نازل وبالتالي كانت غير راغبه في ان
هي تطورت في اي حروب او عمليات عسكريه
خارج حدودها
وبالتالي يعني المساله ديت تمسكت به الى
حد اهمال قواتها المسلحه وده مساله تحدثنا
عنها قبل ذلك وانه الجيش الالماني نتيجه
خجل الالمان من دورهم في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه على وجه التحديد وتاريخهم العسكري
الدموي جدا اهملوا الجيش الى درجه انه
اصبح عاجزا عن القيام بمهام رئيسيه بسيطه
وهم الان في اطار تطوير هذا الجيش ودي
مساله سوف تاخذ سنوات هذا اولا
الاعتبار الثاني اعتبار عسكري انه طبعا
قبل ما انتقل الى الاعتبار العسكري
المانيا بدات بالفعل يعني تدريجيا في
العقود الثلاثه الماضيه ان هي تخالف
توجهها الاستقرت عليه من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبدات تشارك في عمليات حفظ السلام
في دول المعينه ثم انتقلت من عمليات حفظ
السلام للمشاركه في عمليات العسكريه ضمن
تحالفن وهي مشاركه محدوده في الحرب حرب
التحالف اللي قادته امريكا في افغانستان
بعد احداث 11 سبتمبر في الحرب التي تمت في
صربيا في التسعينات اعطت اسلحه للقوات
الكرديه ل همم دعمتها في حربها على
الجماعات المتطرفه وتحديدا داعش لكن ظلت
مشاركه الالمان في عمليات عسكريه خارج
حدودها محدوده جدا
اخر ما تتمناه المانيا ان تكون اول مشاركه
فعليه لسلاحها ان يكون ضد روسيا الدوله
الكبيره جدا وفي تدوروا رحاها في منطقه
جوارها بالقرب من حدودها وده بياخذنا الى
الاعتبار الثاني وهو الاعتبارات العسكريه
المانيا تشعر بان هذه الحرب يمكن ان تتطور
واذا تطورت هذه الحرب سوف تكون المانيا في
فوهه المدفعه على عكس دول اخرى مثل
الولايات المتحده او جيرانها الاوروبيين
فرنسا وبريطانيا هي ليست دوله نوويه اذا
ساءت الامور وقررت روسيا الرد فسوف تفكر
روسيا مرتين قبل ان تستهدف الدول النوويه
لكنها لن تفكر بنفس العمق اذا ارادت ان
تستهدف دول اوروبيه غير نوويه
واذا امدت
المانيا اوكرانيا بالدبابات المتطوره لبرد
2 يمكن لروسيا ان تعتبرها مشاركه في الحرب
واذا ساءت الامور يمكن لروسيا ان تستهدف
المانيا
هذا اعتبار الثاني الاعتبار الثالث هو في
حقيقه الامر اعتبار انتخابي
موقف المانيا من الحرب قضيه جدليه جدا في
المانيا وقصه يطول شرحها وتستحق ان يتوقف
عندها لاحقا لكن نقدر نقول كده ببساطه ان
المجتمع الالماني منقسم على موقف على ما
يجب ان يكون عليه الموقف الالماني نصف
المجتمع الالماني لا يرغب في دعم اوكرانيا
ولا التورط في هذه الحرب والنصف الاخر
هيعتقد انه من الضروري الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا والوقوف في وجه
بوتين اخر ما يتمناه المستشار الالماني ان
يكون السياسي الذي ياخذ بلاده الى اتون
المعركه لان الجانب اللي رفض للحرب سوف
يكون ضده والجانب الذي يؤيد الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا لن يستمر في دعمه اذا تبين له ان
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا يعني جر المانيا الى
الحرب يتمنى ان لا يكون هذا الخير مطروحا
من اساسي وبالتالي هو متردد متردد وليس هو
وحده ولكن الكثير جدا من السياسيين
الالمان السبب الربع والاخير سبب اقتصادي
المانيا اكثر من اي دوله اخرى حريصه على
استمرار على علاقاتها مع روسيا بعد ان
تسكن المدافع الالمان بيفكره في مرحله ما
بعد الحرب الحرب قصرت انطالت سوف تنتهي
اما العلاقات مع روسيا فهي حريصه جدا على
استمرارها
الالمان بنوا نهضتهم الاقتصاديه واقتصادهم
الضخم على اكتاف ثلاثه الدول الولايات
المتحده الصين وروسيا المظله الدفاعيه
العسكريه التي وفرتها امريكا لالمانيا بعد
الحرب واعفتها من فكره الانشغال بالدفاع
عن نفسها العماله الرخيصه الصينيه
المستثمرين الالمان اقاموا مصانعهم هناك
على الاراضي الالمانيه حيث الايدي العامله
الرخيصه وطبعا الطاقه الروسيه الرخيصه جدا
المانيا لا تريد التضحيه بواحد من الدعائم
الثلاثه الاقتصادها القوي للاسباب الاربعه
دول كان الالمان ولمده 11 شهر مترددين جدا
في ان يوافقوا على الطلب الروسي
الطلب اسف الاوكراني
ولذلك رفضوا في البدايه ثم مع الضغط
الغربي اشترطوا اذا انتم مصرين ان انا
اقدم الدبابه ليبر 2 يجب ان اكون جزءا من
تحالف كل دوله تقدم دباباتها وانا اشارك
مثل اي دوله اخرى يعني اكلوا ولا اقود
اتبع ولا اتبع
واشترطوا تحديدا ان تقوم امريكا اللي هي
الدوله الاكبر بتقديم دباباتها ام 1
ابرامز الى اوكرانيا ثم هي تطلق الولايات
المتحده في البدايه امريكا رفضت وكان
متعلمه يعني بانه الدبابه انه 1 غير
مناسبه الى الاجواء الاخرانيه هي دبابه
ضخمه جدا اكثر من 70 طن فبحجمها ده هي لن
تكون مناسبه للطرقات والميدان المعركه لن
تستطيع عبور الكثير من القصور هي مكلفه
جدا
بتاعها او محركها مثل محركات الطائره
النفاثه بيستخدم وقود الطائرات النفاثه في
مكلف صيانتها معقده تحتاج وقت طويل
للتدريب على عكس ليبر 2 اللي هي سوف تكون
اسهل واقتصاديه اكبر وبالتالي رفض الالمان
رفض الامريكان في البدايه ثم مع اصرار
الالماني يبدو انهم توصلوا الى صيغه ان
يعطي الامريكان الاوكران عدد ولو محدود من
ام 1 ابرامز اللي هي الدبابه الامريكيه
الاهم يعني في الترسانه الامريكيه
هناك تقارير مبداها تقول ان البنت تكون
وافق على امداد الاوكران بحوالي 30 قطعه
من هذه الدبابات بالاضافه الى بعض وحدات
الصيانه
للتعامل مع هذه الدبابه في ميدان المعركه
لتشجيع المانيا ورفع الحرج عنها حتى توافق
على اعطاء ليفربول الى الاوكران وموافقه
على كل الدول الاوروبيه التي سوف تتقدم
بطل
لالمانيا
الموافقه على اعاده تصدير الدباباتها الى
اوكرانيا هذه الصوره حتى الان لكن كل اللي
انا قلته ده هو تفاصيلهم يعني في النهايه
اذا لم يكن الالمان اذا لم يستطع الاخران
الحصول على ليبرتو كان حلف شمال الاطلسي
سوف يبحث عن بدائل الجدل النهارده عن على
ليبرتي 2 بالامس كان موجود على همم يعني
همم
انظمه الدفاع الجوي صواريخ هيمارس
غيرها من منظومه التسليح المختلفه وغدا
سوف يكون الجدل على منظومات تسليح ربما
لدول الاخرى فرنسا هولندا فنلندا الى اخره
الحرب تتطور واحتياجات اوكرانيا تزيد
وبالتالي المشكله الرئيسيه او ال- ال-
العامل الرئيسي هو ان يحدد الغرب موقفها
ومن هذه الحرب
انا قلت لحضراتكم قبل كده انه بعد حوالي
سنه من مرور الحرب هناك امور واضحه وامور
غير واضحه الواضح جدا ان الحرب تتطور يوما
بعد يوم يتسعدها الواضح جدا ان الطرفيه
الحرب الرئيسيه قد حسموا موقفينما الروس
عازمون على الاستمرار في هذه الحرب حتى
تحقيق اهدافهم واخرانيا مصره على
الاستمرار في الحرب حتى تحقيق اهدافها
اهداف روسيا عكس اهداف اوكرانيا اهداف
روسيا ببساطه هو
السيطره على كم الاوكرانيا بشكل مباشر او
غير مباشر بشكل مباشر يعني ان تقتطع منها
حوالي 17 او 18% من اراديها الاقاليم
الاربعه خرسون وزابولوجيا وجمهوريتي
الجمباز بالاضافه الى شبه جزيره القرم
وتقوم باخضاع باقي اوكرانيا لتكون دوله
تابعه لها لا يمكن ان تنضم الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي هذا هو الهدف الروسي فيما ان
الهدف الاوكراني عدم القبول بكل هذه
الشروط واجلاء الجنود الروسي عن كل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما فيها شبه جزيره
القرم واكثر من ذلك يضغطون في حاله هزيمه
يعني الروس بتقديم الكثير من السياسيين
والعسكريين منهم الى محاكمات دوليه كمجريه
حرب واجبارهم على دفع تعويضات على الحقيقه
باكرانيا من خسائر وبالتالي الهدفين
واضحين وبالتالي الحرب سوف تضل مستمر
يتبقى ان يحسن الغرب موقفه الغرب دي كلمه
كبيره في اربع دول فقط حسمت موقفها تماما
في المعسكر الغربي الاربع دول دي هي دول
البلطيق الثلاث اللي هي استونيا ولادفيا
وليتوانيا بالاضافه الى بولندا الاربعه
دول موقفهم زي موقف اوكرانيا متشدد جدا
يسعون للضغط على كل دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
الذين ينتمون اليه لمواصله الحرب حتى
هزيمه روسيا واجلائها بالكامل عن اوكرانيا
ويتمنون لو يتم تفكيك روسيا بالكامل
والمساله ببساطه ان لديهم ارث تاريخي مر
جدا مع الامبراطوريه الروسيه ثم مع
الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم مع روسيا الاتحاديه
ويشعرون ببساطه انه هيثبتهم كده اذا
انتصرت روسيا في هذه الحرب فسوف يكون
الاهداف التاريخيه
لكن باقي الدول لديها مواقف متبينه ولديهم
تردد كبير سر التردد ده الى حبينا ان احنا
ننقزه هو ان هذه الدول الولايات المتحده
وباقي دول ال اييي حلف شمال الاطلسي ومنهم
المانيا فرنسا الى اخره هم في حاله حيره
كبيره باختصار هم لا يتحملون ان تنتصر
روسيا في هذه الحرب وهم لا يتحملون ايضا
ان تهزم روسيا في هذه الحرب اذا انتصرت
روسيا في هذه الحرب فهذا يعني ان روسيا
سوف تنتقل بجنودها واسلحتها من منطقه
المنطقه العازله اللي كانت بتقوم بها
اوكرانيا الى العمق الاوروبي الغربي وتكون
روسيا على الحدود الالمانيه والحدود
البولنديه وسوف تكون هناك الدول الاخرى
همم يعني اهدافا محتمله لعدوان روسي مقبل
في السنوات التاليه روسيا سوف تصبح اقوى
بكثير
سوف تضعف كثيرا حلف شمال الاطلسي قد يتفكك
لانه عجز عن الدفاع عن همم يعني امن هذه
الدول في اوروبا
وبالتالي حلف شمال الاطلسي الولايات
المتحده لا تتحمل ان تنتصر روسيا في هذه
الحرب وهذا واضح قلناه قبل ذلك وسوف نتحدث
عنه بالتفصيل بعد ذلك ماذا لو انتصرت
روسيا في هذه الحرب لكن ايضا كل هذه الدول
لا تتحمل هزيمه روسيا اذا في هذه الحرب
اذا هزمت روسيا نتيجه تدفق الاسلحه
الغربيه التقليديه المتطوره على الجيش
الاوكراني هذا يعني حشر روسيا في الزاويه
وقد تضطر في هذه الحياه الى التصعيد
واستخدام السلاح النووي الامر الذي يعني
كارثه للجميع لا يمكن التحكم في عواقبها
وتبيعاتها وبالتالي هذه الدول لم تحسم
موقفها بعد عندها موقف مولانا الموقف
المعلن ده استنز في روسيا الموقف المعل-
المعلن ده
ودعم اوكراني حتى تنتصر على
روسيا الموقف المعلن ان تهزم روسيا بحيث
يتم اجبارها على الجلوس على مائده
المفاوضات لكن هذا كلام عام غير محدد الى
اي حد يمكن ان يذهبوا في دعمهم الى
اوكرانيا ما هو تعريف النصر لاوكرانيا هل
يتضمن مثلا ان تسترد اوكرانيا شبه جزيره
القرم التي تعتبرها روسيا ارض روسيه مقدسه
الى متى يمكن ان تظل تمد اوكرانيا
بمنظومات تسليح تلحق خسائر ضخمه بالقران
ومنها دبابه لبرد 2 التي تمثل تغيير في
قواعد اللعبه هناك اسئله كثيره لم يتم
حسمها وبالتالي المشكله ليست في ليفربول 2
جزء من صوره كبيره الصوره الكبيره تقول ان
الازمه الكبيره التي سوف تظهر في الشهور
المقبله هو الموقف الغربي الحقيقي من هذا
الصراع والذي معه ان شاء الله يكون لنا
حلقات الاخرى اشكركم